[Music]
call the army heck call your mom because
the end
is here
giant bugs are now roaming the earth if
these behemoths existed would humanity
become bug food
how could a bird save your life
and why would grandma's jewelry come in
handy
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if giant bugs roamed the earth
we don't have to watch old monster
movies to wonder what it would look like
if giant insects ran the planet
just step into the what if time machine
and look at our past
over 300 million years ago these
monsters were everywhere
yeah the mega nura an early dragonfly
relative had a wingspan of over 60
centimeters
so
why don't we see these buzzing behemoths
today
these days atmospheric oxygen hovers
around 21 but during prehistoric times
oxygen levels could reach almost 35
percent
if the levels rose that high now you
would need masks and suits to avoid
oxygen poisoning
but during these oxygen-rich times
insects competed with birds for
resources
the faster and more agile birds won out
over the insects and
learned to eat them
eventually insects began to shrink to
the size we know today but if they were
suddenly huge
would you have to become nocturnal
with instantly elevated oxygen levels
bugs wouldn't be the only ones getting a
growth spurt
trees could grow up to 30 meters and
even your everyday ferns could be
massive
and crawling around on the forest floor
giant millipedes almost two meters long
yeah these things would be everywhere
eating decaying matter and plants
nothing to worry about right
come on this is what if you know better
than that
those dragonflies we saw earlier would
be back and in a big way
dragonflies today are deadly predators
with great vision
they bite into their prey's head and fly
it back to a nice secluded spot where
they devour everything
only now
humans would be on their menu
your only chance to strike down this
winged menace would be in their early
developmental stage before their tough
exoskeletons are fully formed
getting them first while they're still
learning to fly may seem like fighting
dirty but
this world won't cut you any slack
and you might just have a meal for later
just remember to aim for the eyes but
what if you needed something stronger to
take down these creatures
the average insects exoskeleton consists
of wax protein strands and other
elements layered together to protect
them from their daily dangers
even their muscle attachments between
their limbs made from a biopolymer
material called chitin are six times
stronger than human tendons
yeah getting through an exoskeleton with
conventional weapons
wouldn't be easy
but a diamond tipped bullet or drill bit
might be strong enough to pierce this
outer shell
maybe you could strap a diamond to a
spear
scientists have even been working on
creating hexagonal diamonds stronger
than anything available now
with these lumbering threats around they
better speed up the process
now depleting oxygen levels stopped
these bugs before so could it stop them
again
maybe over time
if humans keep burning fossil fuels and
dumping carbon dioxide into the air we
might see these bugs shrink in size over
decades but
that might not be fast enough
so
how would we fight back
sometimes the best way to stop a
predator is with another predator
you might want to breed large birds to
protect you since they eat dragonflies
and other insects
and that age-old battle between insects
and birds would start again
but leave the parakeet at home
you'd need a hawk or a trained eagle to
fight these giant bugs
although even these predators wouldn't
be immune from attacks
maybe you wouldn't have to worry about
an oversized daddy longlegs spider but
the goliath bird eater
well that's a different story
when they were normal size
your pet bird would be in danger
i mean it's in the name
so if you got caught in this beefed-up
version's web
it could be fatal
normally their venom wouldn't
necessarily kill you but getting a giant
sized dose of venom in your blood
could end your life before you even knew
what happened
uh that's grim
and even that fate is better than if you
met a wasp in this world
yeah giant wasps might be able to
paralyze you with one sting
and unfortunately it's not done with you
yet
no this insect would take you back to
their nest where you would be eaten
alive by their larvae
so
how would you stop these attacks
well since wasps have poor vision at
night your best bet would be to strike
after the sun went down
destroying their nest in a sneak attack
humans would have to adapt to the dark
to deal with the new threats to our
existence
but don't destroy the larvae just yet
this payback
is gonna be sweet
or well maybe savory
when the world panicked at the sight of
murder hornets some people in japan were
laughing as they pan-fried their grubs
yeah these giant larvae could be
preserved in jars or even steamed with
rice
a wasp shish kebab could be tasty
i mean if they don't skewer you first
this world would create a never-ending
battle between humans and insects
and
victory would go to whoever's hungriest
even with these giant bugs roaming the
earth
we would still have the brains and brawn
to fight back
but now what if these oxygen levels had
the same effect on humans
yeah what if you grew to be five meters
tall
well stick around beanpoles because
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
i